في احياء مدينه باخمه المهجوره شرق البلاد
يسمع باستمرار دوي الانفجارات في مؤشر على
احتدام المعارك في محيطها بين الجيش
الروسي الذي يحاول منذ تسعه اشهر محاصره
المدينه والجنود الاوكرانيين الذين يرفضون
التراجع عن مهمه الدفاع عنها
نجاحا استراتيجيا الاثنين امر الرئيس
الاوكراني
نافيا التكهنات بشان انسحاب قواته امام
الجيش الروسي
يكونو
في الاسابيع الاخيره تقدمت القوات الروسيه
في شمال وجنوب المدينه وقطعت ثلاثه من طرق
الامداد الاربعه للقوات الاوكرانيه وفي
وقت يشكك فيه محللون في جدوى تمسك بهذه
المدينه يقول معهد الابحاث الامريكي
لدراسه الحرب ان الدفاع عن ضخموت لا يزال
منطقيا من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه لان هذه
العمليه تواصل استفاد القوات والمعدات
الروسيه